DANIEL SIEBERG: Hi there, I'm
Daniel Sieberg, as we continue
with day two of I/O Live.
We find ourselves in the
Google Maps sandbox.
And I am joined right now
by Mike from Envista.
How are you, Mike?
Good to see you.
So talk to me a little bit about
how you tapped into the
Google Maps API.
Your overlaying a lot of really
civic information with
regards to, say, city planning,
or construction.
Give me an overview of
what Envista's all
about first of all.
MIKE WALSH: Sure.
Envista is about putting
business data for both our
municipalities and utilities
onto a geolocated map.
In this case, we've use Maps
Engine underneath to take some
of their static data,
including pipeline
information, and things like
that, and overlay dynamic
information.
As you can see, our project we
actually highlighted brings up
both the project information and
the contractors that are
working on it.
So the unified collection of
business data and geolocated
data allows us to share
it between utilities,
municipalities, different
departments, different
audiences, including the
public, eventually.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And what
is this hoping
to solve, in a sense?
I mean, previous to this, or if
a city planner didn't have
access to this information,
what might happen?
Confusion between different
groups?
MIKE WALSH: Yeah, the biggest
thing we find is that data's
spread out across different
organizations
and different systems.
This platform, the combination
of Maps Engine and our own
tool set allows us to provide
the services to bring that
information together.
We talk about collaboration
around geolocated assets.
But it really comes down to
being able to share the
information between the people
who need it, and in the end,
try and solve some problems,
like who's working on which
project where?
When's it going on?
And what's it going to impact?
DANIEL SIEBERG: Can you give
us a little bit of a closer
view of what we're looking
at on the screen here?
MIKE WALSH: Sure.
If we look at here, we have the
straight, solid lines here
represents different projects,
by a particular gas
company in this case.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK,
right in here?
MIKE WALSH: Over here?
The big area here is actually
transmission lines.
And that buffer zone is places
where they have to be aware
that if there's a facility, like
a hospital or a school,
that needs to be evacuated, they
need to have coordination
with the first responders in
a plan to get people out of
there during an evacuation.
So that information together
allows them to do some
planning when they
have a project.
You know, what are we
going to impact when
we go into the ground?
So that type of information
is what's on the map.
But they also have a lot of
information in this case.
Project information coming
from the work management
system is represented
down here, as well
as the contact list.
As I said, which subcontractors
are actually
working on this, and who needs
access to see the information
for this particular project.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Walk me through
what the development
process was like for you guys.
Any learnings you had along the
way, something you want to
share with other developers?
Yeah, I think the big thing is
we saw Maps Engine back this
time last year at I/O, and
discovered that because it
does such a good job of getting
the base map and our
custom data represented in
the map and with great
performance, regardless of
scale, it was a great starting
point for us.
So we started there.
And then on the browser side, we
actually used the Maps API
to do some-- as I said, the
dynamic drawing on top gets us
access to the information
to do the coordination.
So when we click on a feature
here, for instance, we can get
to the same information
on the business side.
So the ability to use both the
backend server services by
Maps Engine, and on the client
side and the browser allows us
to put together some pretty
powerful tools for our
application.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Where has
been adopted so far?
I know you've got some use cases
listed on your website.
But--
MIKE WALSH: Yeah,
we just started.
We have a handful of utilities
that have agreed to start
working with the platform
for us.
We also have a number
of cities that
started working it.
And because it's relatively
new, we've had a lot of
encouraging feedback about the
ability to bring different
parts together.
So we expect to have a lot of
good success in the second
half of it.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Cool.
Thank you so much for giving
insight to this, Mike.
Really appreciate it.
All the best.
MIKE WALSH: Thank you.
DANIEL SIEBERG: We continue our
tour in the Google Maps
sandbox with Ben from this
little known school, Harvard,
I think you called it.
Harvard University.
And a fascinating project that
you've been working on called
the Harvard WorldMap.
Tell me a little bit about
it from some a high level
overview, first of all.
Explain to people what
it's all about.
BEN LEWIS: Sure.
So the vision behind WorldMap
is, what if everybody in the
world could upload big,
geospatial data to the cloud,
analyze it, overlay it.
control access to it, and
collaborate around it, such
that we can generate
new knowledge?
So why would Harvard want to
open something like this up to
the entire world to
upload data to?
Well, it turns out that most of
the best data in the world
isn't actually at Harvard.
So build a great platform, and
people come and use it.
And everybody will win, is sort
of basically the idea.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK, fantastic.
Well, let's just
see an example.
This is the actual WorldMap
site, first of all.
So people can actually upload
their own mapping data, if
they'd like, to their
geospatial data?
BEN LEWIS: Right.
So anybody can come in here,
create a map, and be brought
into a blank template, start
adding data layers in about
five different ways, uploading
data from the hard drive,
creating layers and digitizing
online, uploading scanned
maps, and georeferencing them
online using Map Warper.
This was developed by a company
called Entropy Free.
It's an open source online
georeferencing platform.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And then you've
got an example, if you
can pull up the Africa map.
This is a researcher at Harvard
who worked on this
particular project?
BEN LEWIS: Yes.
So this was developed by a
Professor named Suzanne Blier.
And she uses this to gather
together in one place all of
the valuable map data
sets on Africa.
He's got hundreds of data layers
here, from ethnicity to
social conflict, health,
historic mapping,
transatlantic slave trade.
This is ethnographic mapping
for the continent.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Using
Google Maps API.
BEN LEWIS: Google Maps API
is behind all of this.
So down at the bottom here,
you'll see one has a choice of
lots of different Google
Map bases.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And you can pick
and choose which filters
you'd like two render
on the map.
You can zoom in to different
regions.
BEN LEWIS: Right.
So all of these can be styled.
There's a sophisticated styling
interface here.
You can overlay one
with another.
So this is ethnicities
now overlaid
upon population density.
And we could zoom in and out.
And this goes down to a very
fine level of detail.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's
fascinating stuff.
Now, let's just move on to
maybe the Twitter health
trends that you were talking
about earlier.
BEN LEWIS: So AfricaMap Map is
sort of a typical mapping
application that somebody's
built from scratch without
having to be a developer.
This is kind of the future
direction of WorldMap.
This is a platform that's
being called Geops.
It was developed by
Todd Mostak--
who's a researcher
at Harvard--
together with us.
This is about big data, big
geospatial data on the web.
It uses a couple of GPUs to
make possible on the fly
queries and heatmap generation
for 125 million tweets.
So those are the tweets
themselves.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So
you can see them
represented on the map there.
BEN LEWIS: Do you mind if
I do one query here?
DANIEL SIEBERG: Sure.
BEN LEWIS: So let's
try, tornado.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So these are
people tweeting about a
particular event.
BEN LEWIS: Exactly.
References, say, to tornadoes.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Well, that's
really cool stuff.
So then if people want
to check this out,
where can they go?
BEN LEWIS: This isn't
live, yet.
DANIEL SIEBERG: But the original
stuff we talked
about, worldmap.harvard.edu?
BEN LEWIS: Everything
else is live.
Yeah, this will be live
within a month.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So
worldmap.harvard.edu, though,
is the original site?
BEN LEWIS: Worldmap.harvard.edu.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK, great.
Thank you so much.
BEN LEWIS: Thank you.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right, we're
joined now by Steve, who
may be familiar to many folks.
Formerly with Reddit, now a
co-founder and CTO within
Hipmunk, an increasingly popular
travel app for folks,
and a travel site where you can
book flights and hotels.
But today, we are, of course,
going to focus on Google Maps,
and how you tie that in with
people's hotel booking.
So walk me through what
we're looking at here.
STEVE HUFFMAN: OK, sure.
So this is our main
map display.
And so what we have here is a
search that we did in San
Francisco for a weekend
or two from now.
As you see, it's dominated by
the map, because we felt that
knowing where you're saying is
probably the most important
thing-- especially if you've
never been to a city before--
just kind of intuitively seeing
the geography, the lay
of the land.
So we represent the hotels as
dots on this grid here.
And the reason we lay things out
on the grid is if we had
showed every hotel in the city,
it would just be a big
splotch of dots.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And you wouldn't
get the relations to
where everything
else is, right?
STEVE HUFFMAN: You know, what's
beneficial about the
splotch of dots is that you
can see kind of where big
streets are.
But on Hipmunk, we've kind
of split the difference.
And you can see Lombard Street
here is a popular
neighborhood, and Fisherman's
Wharf.
And then here, the Tenderloin,
or as we would describe it to
tourists, the hotel district.
And that gives us a nice feel.
And then we do is we basically
take the top 10 hotels as
sorted by Ecstasy, and
we highlight those.
So those are the hotels we
think you should stay on,
basically based on the area
you're looking at, the price
of those hotels, the quality
and review scores.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And for people
who know Hipmunk, that's a
reference to the Agony
and Ecstasy rankings.
STEVE HUFFMAN: Right.
When you do a flight search,
we sort by Agony.
And a hotel search is Ecstasy.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
So then these dots here, the
other ones are represented as
different colors.
That's all tied in
to this ranking.
STEVE HUFFMAN: So
we've basically
got three price buckets.
The green are the cheapest
hotels, the red are the most
expensive, and the blue
are the average ones.
Now, you can filter these down,
if you just want to see
cheap hotels, for example.
By default, we just
show everything.
And we let the Ecstasy
sort do the rest.
Now, what's cool about these
buckets is it varies by city.
What's cheap in San
Francisco is
nonexistent in New York City.
And the town i grew in Virginia,
you know, $140 is
probably the most expensive
hotel you're going to find.
So we try to give you a sense,
though, of what the value is.
Are you paying the market rate
or not, effectively.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Cool.
Any offerings to other
developers on the experience
you went through, using
the Maps API?
STEVE HUFFMAN: Sure.
There's something about the
Maps API that are really,
really nice.
I mean, obviously, the
maps themselves work.
You get all this dragging
and zooming and all
that stuff for free.
One of the cool features
we added is heatmaps.
So we computed heatmaps
of all the hot
places to be in a city.
Right now, I have the food
heatmap turned on.
And it's actually really cool.
We just computed these
tiles, name them
with a special format.
And then Google Maps does the
rest, lays them out, loads
them, all the different
zoom levels.
It's actually really neat.
And we got the most, like, bang
out of that feature for
developer hours, ever.
It was actually really
simple to do.
But it looks really,
really awesome.
And that's really cool.
There's some other
stuff we do.
Actually, I'll turn on
my calendar here.
This integrates with my Google
Calendar, which is another
Google API.
And then I can show, in the
city, where I need to be.
So if you're a business traveler
and you've got things
do, you can actually see.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So you could
almost know if you need to
walk. or you could just
walk somewhere.
STEVE HUFFMAN: Exactly.
And if I click the sort by
distance here, I can choose
one of events.
And it'll show me just hotels
near that event.
Or it'll take the hotels near
that event, and then sort them
by Ecstasy.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's
fantastic.
All right.
Well, Steve, thank
you so much.
Full disclosure, I used Hipmunk
to find my way here
from New York.
So thank you so much
for that demo.
Appreciate it.
And we finish up our tour in the
Google Maps sandbox with
Peter, who is a Product Manager
with Google Earth.
And in a sense, we are going
to get our own personal
helicopter tour here, right?
PETER BIRCH: Absolutely.
So we're really excited.
Yesterday, here at I/O, we
announced the launch of this
new 3D imagery technology
in Google
Earth for Android devices.
And behind us, here, we have a
demonstration showing what
some of this imagery actually
looks like in what we call our
Liquid Galaxy, which is this
great way to view this data.
But what's going on here is
that Google Earth has been
around for a long time.
We've been doing 3D for years.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Right, people
are already familiar with 3D
buildings, maybe the 3D
Warehouse or something.
But now--
PETER BIRCH: Absolutely.
So now what we really realized
was that we needed to step it
up a notch, right?
We really needed to increase
the scale, the consistency,
and the coverage of
the 3D buildings.
And we just really needed to
figure out how to notch it up.
And so what we're doing is we
have this new 3D imagery,
where we're actually using
aerial imagery from planes,
where they shoot four
different angles.
DANIEL SIEBERG: It's very
specific patterns that they
have to fly to gather
all of this?
PETER BIRCH: Exactly.
So we shoot, basically,
forwards, back, left, right,
and then straight down.
So there's a fifth shot
that's straight down.
And then from that,
we're able to
automatically generate 3D data.
So the things you're looking at
here is all auto generated
using something called
stereophotogrammetry, where
we're actually using the
different images to extract
the 3D data.
And then we actually take that
and we texture it, or we sort
of color of the geometry
with the actual photos.
DANIEL SIEBERG: I almost think
of as like digital sculpting,
or something.
But it's pretty amazing
looking.
PETER BIRCH: Yeah, I mean, it's
phenomenal how far the
technology has gone, and being
able to have the resources of
not only the talented engineers
at Google, but also
the infrastructure that we have
that allows us to build
3D models at this scale
automatically.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.
Now, we're seeing this on bigger
screens, thanks to
Liquid Galaxy.
But in your hand, you've
got a tablet.
And so folks can check this out
in a mobile way, both for
tablets and phones as well.
PETER BIRCH: Absolutely.
And what I have right
here, this is a
Motorola XOOM tablet.
And I don't know if your
viewers will get
the best view this.
So the best way for people to
check this out is to download
it onto your Android device,
whether it's
a phone or a tablet.
It's supported on multicore
phones.
So for example, the great Galaxy
Nexus, as well as a
Samsung Galaxy 2, and the new
3, and a bunch of other
devices, as well as, obviously,
the new Nexus 7,
which we just released.
Works fantastic on
that as well.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Coming soon to
iOS, if people are curious.
PETER BIRCH: And it is coming
soon to iOS as well.
So here you can see,
I'm actually
going through San Francisco.
We've launched about a dozen or
so cities and metro areas,
including San Francisco, LA,
Portland, Rome, Tampa.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And many
more to come, I assume.
PETER BIRCH: Many
more to come.
We got Charlotte, we've
got a bunch more.
And we've stated that we're
going to have the communities
of over 300 million
people covered by
the end of this year.
And we're going to just
keep going from there.
So we're really excited about
being able to bring this kind
of 3D technology to people
around the world.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And I'm sure
lots of folks will look
forward to a desktop version
at some point.
PETER BIRCH: Coming
soon as well.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Coming
soon, sure.
PETER BIRCH: Later this year.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Peter, thank
you so much for this tour.
We're going to land our
helicopter now here in the
Google Maps sandbox.
Stay tuned for lots more
here on I/O Live.